miles de turistas varados en Perú Esta
es otra Arista de la crisis política que
vive la nación suramericana Ah nosotros
ya llevamos aquí el lunes son hoy son
cinco días que estamos aquí con poca
información
de la situación actual del país por
regresar nosotros a la ciudad de cusco
como también otros visitantes también
exigieron una respuesta desde otros
puntos de la geografía peruana en un
hecho similar al menos 60 personas
encontraron retenidas en la ciudad de
chicaupe según los cajeros se
encontraban secuestrados queremos
informar al mundo entero de que
lastimosamente nos encontramos
secuestrados en el país de Perú muchos
de nosotros vinimos por turismo a
visitar este hermoso país nos
encontramos mal por esta situación y a
más de 24 horas es que nos encontramos
sin comer sin tomar agua sin servicios
básicos lastimosamente sin protección de
la policía el estado no nos ha dado unas
respuestas al momento para poder lograr
un paso a nuestros países estamos
completamente cercados acá y obviamente
con la zozobra de ser agredidos
físicamente y es que a nivel nacional el
panorama no parece cambiar en medio de
un estado de emergencia declarado por el
gobierno los manifestantes exigen la
libertad del expresidente Pedro castillo
y la renuncia del actual jefa de estado
Dina boluarte mientras ninguna de las
partes parece ceder en sus objetivos los
extranjeros retenidos en Perú continúan
reclamando retornar a sus lugares de
origen